س ننوه الى الخبر
العاجل اذا الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن
اصابه 48 جنديا بجروح خلال ساعات
ال4 الماضيه وا بل اعتقد انه نجوان نتحدث
عن 90 وليس 48 90 مصابا وجريحا ام ان
التحديث قد
تغير التحديث تغير في المجمل بحسب القائمه
التي صدرت قبل لليل
48 جنديا اصيبوا في المعارك خلال
ال ال 24 ساعه الاخيره عثمان هناك قوائم
ينشرها الجيش الاسرائيلي في موقعه وفي كل
يوم يعدل العدد الاجمالي للاصابات وهي
تشمل اصابات غزه واصابات ايضا الجبهه
الشماليه ولكن بالعاده اعداد قليله جدا من
الجنود يكونون قد اصيبوا في الجبهه الش
شماليه في لبنان غالبيه الجنود بل
الغالبيه العظمى يصابون في معركه غزه
وتحديدا داخل قطاع غزه في المعارك البريه
بعد ان تم تعديل الارقام نحن ننظر الى ما
تم نشره يوم امس وما يتم نشره اليوم
بالعاده يقوم الجيش الاسرائيلي بتحديث هذه
الارقام خلال ساعات النهار
فقد ذكر بان هناك 48 جنديا عمليا نقلوا
الى المستشفيات منذ يوم امس خلال ال
24 ساعه يقول بان هذا العدد طبعا نتحدث عن
الاجمالي للاصابات منذ بدايه الحرب على
غزه
1831 جنديا اصيبوا منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
289 في حاله خطيره ومنذ بدايه العمليه
البريه يقول الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي
هناك
704 جنود اصيبوا خلال المعارك داخل غزه من
بينهم 160 في حاله صعبه اذا هذه هي
الارقام المحدثه الان الارقام النهائيه
التي حدثها الجيش الاسرائيلي في موقعه اي
وهو بعد الانتقادات الواسعه التي سمعت
تحديدا في وسائل في وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه عن انه لا يقوم بتحديث
الاصابات في صفوف الجنود قبل نحو اسبوعين
عندما صدر تقرير من صحيفه دعوت احرونوت
تحدثت فيه عن ان الاصابات في حينه قبل
اسبوعين بين صفوف الجنود بلغت 5000 اصابه
من بينها الفانك وصفها بالاصابات الخطيره
ممن تعرضوا الى بتر في الاطراف واصبحوا
معاقين لكن بعد ساعات فقط على نشر هذا
الخبر تم ازاله العدد 5000 مصاب من هذا
الخبر في دعوت احرونوت وبعد يوم واحد فقط
جراء هذا النشر ططر كما يبدو الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى بدء
نشر اعداد المصابين الى جانب القتلى بين
صفوفه لكن طيله الوقت الاعداد التي يتحدث
عنها الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي اقل بكثير من القوائم التي
تنشرها المستشفيات التي تتعامل وتستقبل
الجنود لتقديم ال العلاج وهذا يظهر جليا
في قوائم المستشفيات تحديدا مستشفى سوروكا
في بئر السبع وهي اكبر واقرب مستشفى الى
منطقه غلاف غزه وهي من استقبلت العدد
الاكبر من المصابين الجنود في اليوم الذي
نشر فيه الجيش الاسرائيلي بعد تقريره دعوت
احرونوت عن
1400 او خ 500 من المصابين اجمالي
المصابين للجيش من منذ بدايه الحرب في ذلك
اليوم نشرت سوروكا ان ما ما تعاملت معه من
اصابات فاق ال 2000 وبالتالي هذا فقط يؤكد
عن هذه هذه الفجوه الكبيره وهذا ما اكدته
ايضا صحيفه هارس التي اجرت تحقيقا ونشرت
فيه كل القوائم للمستشفيات الاسرائيليه
ونتحدث عن عدد كبير من المستشفيات التي
تستقبل وتقدم العلاج للجنود سواء كان في
بئر السبع او في عسقلان او في مدينه تل
ابيب وحتى في مدينه القدس ينقل الى
مستشفياتها ايضا عدد من المصابين ونرى
طيله الوقت هناك صور تخرج من هذه
المستشفيات للمروحيات العسكريه التابعه
لفرقه الانقاذ في سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
التي تعرف سته بسته 69 وهي طيله الوقت
تهبط في هذه المستشفيات وتنقل ايه جرحى من
الجنود وحتى هذا العدد 48 مصابا ربما هذه
المره الاولى التي يتحدث فيها الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن هذه الارقام خلال 24 ساعه
من المصابين صباح هذا اليوم فقط كان هناك
اعلان عن اصابه بالغه اصيب فيها احد
الجنود الى جانب الجندي الذي قتل يوم امس
في شمال قطاع غزه بعد ان استهدفا مباشره
في صاروخ مضاد للدر
استهدف الهامر او الجب العسكري الذي كان
كان بداخله بالاضافه الى اصابه بالغه اخرى
تحدثت عنها وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
صباح هذا اليوم عن كانت الى جانب ثلاثه من
القتلى الذين قتلوا في معركه خان يونس يوم
امس ايضا جراء تعرضهم
لانفجار ل بعبوه ناسفه بالاضافه الى اطلاق
النار على هذه القوه التي تواجدت هناك وفي
وذلك كفي اشاره الى الكمائن التي تعدها ال
المقاومه الفلسطينيه كتائب القسام في داخل
قطاع غزه طيله الوقت عثمان نسمع من
المواقع التي نرصد فيها عمليات القصف
المستمره سواء كان في المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه في منطقتي بيت حنون وبيت لاهيه
وايضا هذه المناطق الشرقيه طيله الوقت
هناك تحليق للمروحيات العسكريه جزء منها
بطبيعه الحال هي المروحيات التي تشارك في
عمليات القصف وهي من نوع اباتشي لكن ايضا
نرى في بعض الاحيان الهليكوبترات او
المروحيات التي تقل الجنود المصابين مساء
هذا اليوم يتوقع ان تصدر اعدادا وارقا
وقوائم من المستشفيات الاسرائيليه وايضا
سنقوم باجراء مقارنه بين ما ينشره الجيش
الاسرائيلي من عدد للاصابات وبين ما يتم
نشر في المستشفيات وكما ذكرنا بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بدا اصلا بنشر هذه المعطيات
بعد الاحراج الذي سببته وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه بنشر هذه المعطيات وهذه
القوائم كان هناك احد الصحفيين
الاسرائيليين العسكريين الذي زار
المستشفيات قبل ايام قليله ونشر تقريرا عن
وضعيه المستشفيات وقال ان هناك مشاهد
قاسيه يصعب احتمالها لمعاق قين من جنود
الجيش الاسرائيلي اصبحوا معاقين جراء هذه
الحرب وان مراكز التاهيل في المستشفيات
الاسرائيليه لم تكن مستعده لعدد كبير من
الجرحى بهذا الحجم خلال هذه الحرب شكرا ن
جوان السمري من غلاف غزه